بعد الهجمات التي شهدها العمق الروسي جاءت
دور على اقليم القرود ليتحمل اثقل الحرب
اوكرانيا النجاحات في نقل المنطقه
الرماديه التي تفصل الحدود الروسيه وخركيز
الى الداخل الروسي لكن موسكو فعلت كل ما
بوسعها من اجل عدم الانجرار وراء فتح جبهه
جديده قد تكون وهميه استراتيجيه التقارير
الروسيه تؤكد ذلك وكما كان متوقعا انطلق
الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد بعد اشهر من
الانتظار وان كانت اوكرانيا تنفيه بشكل
رسمي المفاجاه كانت في تفاصيل الخطه
الاوكرانيه وما سبقها من احداث
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه قام النظام
الاوكراني ببدء هجومه الموعود الذي روج له
طويلا لقد قاموا بالهجوم على محاور عديده
على الجبهه ولقد سخروا لتحقيق هدفهم كميه
كبيره من المعدات والقوات
وزارته الدفاع الروسيه تصرفت وكانها توقعت
تفاصيل الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد والذي لن
يخرج بحسبها من
جنوبولوجيا فاوكرانيا لن تتخلى ببساطه عن
فكره فصل خرسون عن بقيه ان كانت تريد فعلا
استرجاع استرجاع شبه جزيره القرم ايام قبل
الهجوم تعرضت المناطق الحدوديه جنوب
مقاطعه
الى ما معدله 850 قذيفه مدفعيه يوميا معدل
لم تشهده الحرب من قبل وما تحصده روسيا
الان في بيلجرود هو نتيجه لقرار سابق ضم
روسيا لمناطق اوكرانيا لم يشمل مقاطعه
خركيب وهو ما عجل بالانسحاب من مناطق
واسعه بهدف تقليل امتداد الجبهه لكن
الامور تغيرت عندما بدا الجيش الروسي في
بناء التحصينات وجد نفسه مضطرا لتشييدها
في العمق الروسي تجنبا لاستفزاز المدفعيه
الاوكرانيه والتي يصل مداها الى اربعين
كيلو مترا ومع اقتراب الهجوم تحول
الاستفزاز الى مناوشات ثم قصف متواصل وفر
تغطيه
متسلله لتتحول اراضي روسيه الى منطقه
رماديه
[موسيقى]
قصف مقاطعه لا يحمل اهميه
عملياتيه لكن من الواضح انك توافقه مصادر
روسيه التاسعه لتجديد موسكو واستدراج
قواتها نحو جبهه جديده بعيدا عن موقع
الهجوم الحقيقي اوكرانيا هاجمت في خمسه
محاور حمد دبابات اليوبارد ومدرعات اي ام
اكس 10 الفرنسيه لاول مره وهنا دليل اخر
على انطلاق الهجوم المضاد والوجهه كانت
الواقعه بين جبهتي
وزباروجيا منطقه تعتبرها اوكرانيا اضعف
بين الاضعف بين الدفاعات الروسيه لكن
الهجوم لم يحدث كما كان متوقعا جاء الدور
على اوكرانيا لارتكاب اخطاء روسيا قوافل
الدبابات الغربيه وقعت فخا في يد
المروحيات الهجوميه الروسيه كما نشاهد
مشاهدينا
اوكراني اخر نقل المدفعيات نحو بالقرود
افقد كييف القدره على توفير تغطيه كافيه
لسلاح المدفعيه قبل الهجوم نتائج اليوم
الاول كانت تكرارا لبغموت على نطاق واسع
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات